there's a messed up set of incentives
that's baked into the k-12 public school
system
where they get your money regardless of
whether they open their doors for
business so
teachers unions had an incentive to keep
their doors closed
corey deangelis the reason foundation's
director of school choice
has been tracking the impact of the
pandemic on education policy he's found
that a growing number of parents are
leaving traditional public schools and
looking to take their education dollars
with them
at the same time there's growing
frustration with teachers unions for
their continued opposition to reopening
despite mounting evidence that schools
aren't a significant source of
infections
why was it okay for the private schools
to reopen
but not the public schools the public
schools in some places were saying that
we can't open for in-person instruction
because it's too dangerous
but then they were reopening the same
physical
school buildings for in-person child
care activities
d'angelo says that unions have made a
host of ridiculous demands as conditions
for returning to work
but then they started lumping in all
these political demands
in their calls to reopen schools so for
example one of the first teachers unions
to do this was the los
angeles teachers union they wanted to
defund the police they wanted medicare
for all and all these other political
goals that didn't seem like they had a
lot to do with the reopening
of schools with public schools
struggling to provide
quality online education many parents
attempted to transfer their kids into
virtual charter schools
taking their education dollars with them
deangelis says
teachers unions turn to lawmakers to
stop the outflow
the oregon education association lobbied
to the government to make it illegal
for families to switch to schools in
this time of need and you saw similar
actions in places like
california and pennsylvania where the
money wouldn't follow the child to the
charter school
this was an act that protected the
monopoly at the expense of thousands of
families
as a result of slow and incompetent
rollouts of distance learning
students around the country are failing
at much higher rates
so for example in my area fairfax county
public schools
the rate of students who have been
failing two or more classes has
increased by
83 since last year there's been a
nationwide study on this by mckenzie and
company
and they've estimated that students have
lost between one and three
months of education this year and
they've seen
that there have been inequities as well
for
disadvantaged groups of students they've
lost more months of learning
than more advantaged groups of students
the silver lining is that there's
growing recognition that traditional
education
funding is deeply flawed and that money
needs to follow the child
the latest national survey from gallup
estimates that traditional public
schools will
lose about seven percentage points of
their student population
this school year more and more people
are starting to realize
these closed buildings are continuing to
get their children's education dollars
while while they're scrambling and none
of that money is following them to pay
for private school tuition and fees out
of pocket or to help cover the costs
associated with home-based education
86 percent of families now support the
concept of education savings accounts or
what i like to call funding students as
opposed to systems
i've been tracking about 14 states now
this year in january
that have had legislators introduced
bills to fund students
as opposed to systems so states like new
hampshire
utah has a particular bill that's
interesting kansas
and kentucky arizona has a bill to
expand
their already existing school choice
program you have nebraska
you have iowa florida has a bill to
restructure all of their vouchers
a lot of people are figuring out that
there's no good reason to fund
institutions when we can fund students
directly instead